[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une liste qui ressemble à
rambouillet c'est une liste citoyenne et
de rassemblement génération rambouillet
est une équipe entièrement renouvelée
issus de la société civile renforcée par
la présence d'élus d'expérience pour ma
part je m'appuie sur mon expérience de
maire adjoint et d'un vice-président de
l'agglomération rambouillet situé liste
composée de femmes et d'hommes d'une
erreur professionnelle et de quartiers
différents de toutes les générations et
pré insuffler une nouvelle dynamique et
pour la plupart d'entre eux déjà engagés
et investit dans le tissu associatif au
service des rambos liten et des embolies
temps le point phare de notre programme
réside dans le fait qu'il est résolument
vers une un engagement de transition
écologique
il est intergénérationnel et il est
limité financièrement maîtrise la
première décision tant que père bas peut
pas être il peut pas l'avoir tué la
première décision sera bien sûr
actualité oblige à l'accueil des plus
jeunes pour leur propose des activités
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
pour cet été ça sera aussi de préparer
la rentrée scolaire dans un cadre plus
serein pour démarrer une nouvelle année
scolaire et enfin d'accompagner d'aider
tous les acteurs économiques commerçants
artisans entreprises du territoire en
renforçant immédiatement l'économie de
proximité relancer la préférence du
consommer local et de reprendre au plus
vite aux investissements nécessaires à
la relance économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]